Governor DeSantis let's talk politics
for a minute it's been kind of
interesting what's happening with him
yeah um he went on this book tour which
I thought that was pretty lackluster I
mean he didn't make like a big splash it
didn't really help his poll numbers he
went into like only super friendly
places and really didn't make a lot of
news then he went on this little World
Tour where he went on five he went to
five visit five different countries
and
I don't know what to make of it pat
because there was this very nasty report
in Politico about how that went uh in
particular this appearance he made in
Great Britain but you know the Press
hates him so I'm trying to take it with
a grain of salt while still being
open-minded to who he is because we
don't know him well not you know enough
we don't actually know whether this is
why you have a primary like you have to
test the guy and see how but this is
what Politico said they said he met with
more than 50 representatives of major UK
firms and business lobbying groups I
mean duh he's of course running like I
love how we all have to pretend he
hasn't announced yet he might not be
running why the hell would the governor
Florida be doing any of this
um one you one one UK business figure
said to Santa's quote looked bored and
quote stared at his feet quote he had
been to five different countries in five
days and he definitely looked spent but
his message wasn't presidential he was
horrendous
a second business figure who's in the
room said it was a quote low wattage
performance that quote nobody in the
room was left thinking this man's going
places they said It felt really a bit
like we were watching a state level
politician I wouldn't be surprised if
people in attendance came out thinking
that's not the guy so what do we have we
have a left-wing publication citing two
people who are in the room who were
underwhelmed by DeSantis okay
to me that sounds like what the Press is
going to do against any Republican who
might be up and coming but the polls
also show he's struggling he's
struggling within the Republican party
to really resonate uh there are new
polls out just today
or the over the past couple days there's
CBS uggov Trump 58 DeSantis 22 that's
not good
um the previous was Trump 42 DeSantis 32
so it's just 10 point difference in
February Emerson Trump 62 DeSantis 16.
uh previously there had been a 30 point
difference between the two of them in
February
Trump continues to rack up all the
pretty much all the endorsements there
are to get in the Republican party so
where does that leave us right because
how do we factor in left-wing media bias
against Republican candidates and
is DeSantis genuinely faltering because
this stuff about not being able to
really connect with people is a
recurring theme
well you said something I want to say
five weeks ago when you said why are you
not coming onto my podcast to promote
the books or this was six weeks ago when
you said this and I fully agreed with
you I don't understand the marketing
side I don't think they have a strength
when it comes on to the marketing side
see in a company if I were to hire a
Rhonda centers as a president of a
company okay say a GE hires them say a
company that's about driving initiatives
recruiting hitting markers quarterly
numbers doing quarterly call calls I
think he would totally crush it right
because Tim Cook Tim Cook's not a
personality guy you don't go to Tim Cook
and say well Tim Cook if he was only a
little bit more charismatic Apple would
have done better no Tim Cook took Apple
when Steve Jobs died from a hundred
billion dollar company to nearly a three
trillion dollar company that's 30xing a
hundred billion dollar company and
nobody not one person in the world is
going to get up there and saying here's
10 keys to to you know Temple you know
his Tim Cook's uh charismatic
personality we're never going to say
that so in that Arena I think the
scientist would crush it in the arena of
being a leader of a military unit a
general he would crush it when you get
into politics there's this thing called
cameras okay and TV and news and you
have to sell the audience okay Vivek
ramaswani is getting all this momentum
you know who he is you hosted one of the
a great debates right after him and
David Saxman added I thought it was
fantastic what she did we're seeing him
everywhere literally you're seeing him
everywhere he's selling himself he's
selling his ideas a lot of us are going
like this and we're saying actually a
good idea I actually like the way he
handled Don Lemon I actually like the
way he did this and we're starting to
say this more and more and more and it's
kind of like I'm kind of liking this guy
a lot right now let's go to uh Ron
DeSantis we had this conversation today
on our podcast with jedidine Bill and a
bunch of different guys that we had here
and here's what we talked about the
concept of Blue Ocean strategy Blue
Ocean strategy some will say is the
greatest marketing book ever written if
you've never read it you have to read it
that sold five and a half million copies
and it's known as a top 10 best business
books of all time I expect everybody
that works for me to read this book
phenomenal book in the book they give
the formula of how companies and
individuals us can go compete against
somebody that's big in a Marketplace and
not get on a red ocean instead compete
in a blue ocean red ocean is sharks that
are all eating from each other and
there's blood everywhere it's red like I
steal your guys you still my guys I
steal your clients you said I'll give
you a better deal I'll give you better
this I'll pay you more it's a red Ocean
Blue Ocean says no just get away from
that ocean and go into a completely
different Market kind of like yellowtail
the drink used to compete with wine
finally they said no we're not going to
be competing with wine let's go compete
with beer companies and then also they
went and brought beer drinkers because
their drink was six bucks and then boom
they took off right okay let's look at
Rhonda santis the formula is create
eliminate increase decrease okay to
separate yourself
for example when I started my own
insurance company I looked at the
marketplace the average agent was a 56
year old white male is what the average
agent in the insurance industry was it
was 17 women 56 years old and nobody
used social media so I sat there and
said okay I'm gonna eliminate Securities
licenses we're not going to use series
766 we're just gonna do live we're going
to increase social media presence
because no one's using it we're going to
create an environment to Target women
because women can talk to other women
what a decision makes about life
insurance because typically mothers and
wives are more concerned about life
insurance than husbands and fathers are
that's going to be our audience so today
if we put a convention together August
with 15 000 people there the average
agent is going to be a 34 year old
Hispanic female that's what you call a
blue ocean then the market comes and
they buy our company a year ago and it
was a beautiful experience that we had
right let's go to Ron DeSantis as a
product as a product Charisma can you go
face to face against Trump no way you're
not going to win trust me ask Marco
Rubio and Ted Cruz you're not going to
be able to do that uh trolling can he go
up against Trump nope you're talking
about a street brawler from New York
good luck trying to do that side okay
where can he go and do that uh military
background everything he does that needs
to be at a military unit because he
served in the military and he was a Jag
lawyer for Navy SEAL unit all this stuff
Trump can't do that he can't kind of
like remember back in the days when
Dukas has tried to set himself up as a
leader and he's in the tank boom it was
over that is actually an audience that
he can play off of there's 30 million
veterans in America that's a big vote
you can go work off of that and we'll
look at look at this guy he looks like
he's a military guy he looks like the
commander-in-chief if he goes and talks
about his track record during covid is
there anybody above him on handling of
covet are you kidding me you got the
work Chrissy gnome she's there she's not
running yeah you got the well I agree
totally you're right you got the woke
who couldn't stand your policies you
forced them while they had BLM on the
floor to host the NBA finals in Florida
I mean how much of a I would be talking
about that 24 7. AOC came to your state
for vacation during Christmas this
should be like you know the greatest
hits that he can go on Non-Stop now this
is the other part
that sometimes uh Megan if if if let's
just say I'm assuming you assuming you
and Tucker have spoken I'm not asking
for you to answer that I'm just saying
I'm assuming you and Tucker have spoken
why is that an assumption well because
Tucker is probably a good idea for him
to call you why is that a good idea uh
because you've been through this before
okay in a different way but you know
what that experience is to go through
with Fox so he's probably called you I'm
assuming Tucker's probably spoken to
Beck and maybe even spoken to Bill
O'Reilly why because these were all at
one point cream of the crop right there
is wisdom in calling somebody else
that's gone through what you've gone
through
do I think Governor Ron DeSantis has
called others to ask for wisdom of what
to do or do I think their Camp thinks
they know exactly what they're doing I
don't know but if I'm a betting man I'm
more betting on them thinking they know
what they're doing rather than leaning
on others who have been through this
before to say what should we do with our
marketing strategy should I be out there
more I'm in Israel you know I'm doing
this you know hey he's looking tired
what should I be saying when I'm doing
this I think there's an element of that
where you got to bring some of the right
uh supporting casts around you to help
with the strategy uh who knows look in
about two weeks when he's going to be
making an announcement that he's running
because you know he's got a lock in his
Governor position maybe in two weeks
when he comes out Megan he's going to
shock the hell out of all of us he's
going to take the gloves I'm send ready
let's go because I'm free now you were
thinking I was afraid I've not been
afraid I couldn't make the decision
until now let's roll and maybe we're
going to be shocked but until then I
think a lot of the criticism he's
getting is fair
um he's going to be in Iowa at the same
time as Donald Trump which seems like a
disaster waiting to happen I mean like
that seems like taking on Trump and his
territory remember Trump last time in
Iowa was literally giving people free
helicopter rides
he's the marketing guy he gets marketing
Trump is a marketer
true I mean that's how he made most of
his money before the Celebrity
Apprentice was just marketing out his
name and getting paid license fees you
know he didn't actually run these
buildings he let them use the Trump name
which you know used to be not that
controversial it's different now all
those uh buildings along the Upper West
Side were used to ride the West Side
Highway was Trump from Trump not a
single one has that anymore because it's
the Upper West Side uh yeah but it's
tough to have it like Head to Head where
you're trying to charm people and out
charm Trump but I think you're making
good sense I mean like maybe he could
lean in if I were to Sanders I don't
know how to say this because I
complained that he didn't come on the
show and give me an interview because I
really think he should have done that
but I actually if I were if I were
DeSantis I would say go on with somebody
whether it's me or somebody else who can
help you own your foibles your
weaknesses who can help you make fun of
yourself like I would ask him what's
with weird the weird head Bob what are
you doing that like why am I seeing
these videos of you looking like that
it's like kind of off-putting I would
ask him that I asked Putin why he's
doing all these shirtless photos trust
me I would ask DeSantis this question
and then we have a chance you have a
track record of asking those questions
yeah I do and then and then we'd have a
chance to laugh about it I think people
would get to see him be maybe
self-deprecating maybe own like a A
little weirdness about him maybe he's
like a little nerdy you know I don't
know what the like the answer is not to
keep yourself in only protected spaces
even Trump you know next week he's going
to do a town hall on CNN which is like
okay that is not a safe space for Trump
I'm actually kind of curious about the
strategy I don't think there's a lot of
getable Voters on you know watching CNN
right now I see why CNN wants to do it
um but I applaud the decision to sort of
go in places where that are unexpected
you got to respect that right I mean you
know when you when you think about
boxing UFC MMA we like fights you gotta
love the guy that's willing to go
anywhere anytime to brawl and fight
there's something about that that's very
attractive and appealing with Trump
wanting to go on CNN strategically
logically on 70 different points we can
say don't do this it doesn't make any
sense but what's he going to do is Trump
going to wait for Fox to flip their
positions from DeSantis to Trump because
you know a lot of times you're hearing
about the news that you know the fox is
taking a position with uh the scientists
over Trump and even the poll that came
out as a fox poll that's showing Trump
ahead of DeSantis so Trump's not going
to be the one that's going to wait for
Fox to want to support him that's not
his play he will go find a media you
know why because there's certain people
in the world that when you put the
camera in front of them they get
eyeballs people want to know what they
have to say there's not too many of them
he's at the top of that list when he
talks people show up and CNN knows
financially they're making the right
move to get him on there but I know
you're saying is there going to be
anybody to flip there I think you and I
may be surprised how many people are
sitting there and saying really I have
to choose between this guy and and Joe
Biden I mean I mean I I
so many people that are not politically
conservative or libertarian or
independent
Megan Joe Rogan just said if he had to
choose between Biden and Trump he's
going Trump
if you would have said Joseph
he's a lefty he wanted Bernie Sanders
last time he wanted Bernie Sanders so
Elon Musk is now sitting there saying
anything but Biden so you know I think
the uh you don't need as big of an
audience as we think we need you need a
small percentage of people to flip and
if CNN's willing to host it you know
what he's going to do he's going to
troll them he's going to mock a lot of
people he's going to tell a couple jokes
he's going to call on and push his
agenda and they're going to ask him
tough questions he's going to flip it on
them the interviewer is going to be just
as scared as anybody else to interview
him because he knows the interview is
going to flip very very quickly when you
interview somebody like Trump and he's
going to handle it but you know again
the question is conversion you're asking
the right question we're going to find
out 16 months from now whatever the
timeline is 15 months from now 17 months
from now if it's going to work or not it
is an interesting strategy because you
know you've got I realize fox has gone
pro DeSantis though I mean I really
think they need to be open-minded it's
like DeSantis isn't doing very well
right now I know he hasn't declared but
so far it's been a stumble out of the
Starting Gate I think that's fair to say
you got Tim Scott who's about to declare
you got Issa Hutchinson who doesn't
really have much going on you got Nikki
Haley Mike Pence is probably going to
throw his hat in soon he got Vivek who
is very interesting I really hope people
are open-minded to him
um I think vivek's biggest problem is he
kind of looks like the smartest kid in
the class is always correcting everybody
it's like that he's got it like like be
careful you don't want to be that
annoying kid
um but he does know more about virtually
everything than anyone I mean like
there's a reason he's so confident
so they have to keep an open mind
because this is a primary process and it
plays out for over a long period of
months for a reason if you went back and
looked at who is in the lead in April or
May of 2015 which would be the
equivalent of where we are now I believe
it was Jed Bush I'm pretty sure it was
Jeb Bush I went out I interviewed him at
Liberty University it did not go well
and he soon fell out of the first
position and before we knew it Donald
Trump was number one by that August
debate anything can happen
yeah and by the way Jeff had 140 million
dollars to start off with and remember
we used to talk about Walker Oh Walker
you know Walker you know Walker is going
to be the president and the note the
numbers just came back for Florida I
think Wall Street Journal article came
out yesterday talking about the fact
that DeSantis is starting off with 86
million dollars which is a good amount
of money to start off with as well uh uh
give or take on maybe a million dollars
off but he start off with some money as
well this is more than just money you're
gonna need more than money to win this
one here this is going to be ugly it's
going to be nasty uh it's going to be
manipulative it's going to be deceptive
it's going to be strange it's going to
be uh things could change it's going to
be like one of those games that you
watch where you know great football game
or great playoffs game well the score
change 17 different times there was 16
ties and I think this is going to be
that I think it's going to come down to
it well here's here's the here's the
real Capper Trump could be in jail like
the Republicans need to be open-minded
to who else is in the field whether you
like to scientist or not because he's
got by my account at least four
prosecutors coming for him I don't think
much of these prosecutions but that's
not to say a jury will agree with me so
things could get really wacky over the
next couple of years
on the other side I mean you know
they're they're the the president's
granddaughter right now is not being
helped you know which one I'm talking
about hunters yeah
this is not a this is not a good look
but I think the scorecard is going to
change many many times I think it's
going to be nasty I think it's going to
be ugly I think there's a lot of
different possibilities what happens uh
I do believe the debates are going to be
some of the most viewed ever uh uh you
know ratings we're ever gonna see this
is going to be a in the in the media
space and listen if I think about oh
David versus Goliath first of all Joe
Biden is not a Goliath in any ways he he
got elected for many different reasons
but I think this is going to be if you
like the game of politics and you're in
that space which you're selling ideas
man I am so curious to know these
strategic people behind closed doors
what they're going to do is is there is
the left going to leverage like you saw
what he said at the uh the dinner he
says well you know hey there's a lot of
media owners here there's CNBC in here
uh which they own NBC you know the NBC
on CNBC and and there is a Dominion here
which owns Fox News you know those jokes
those are jokes that the writer wrote
that's a very good joke for the writer
to write it's like those moments where
you're gonna see hey if if this is you
keep talking about Fox News you know you
keep talking about fake news you know
how about Fox the fact that they paid a
record-break in 787 to demand these
things are gonna get the audience to be
thinking about well record-breaking man
maybe Fox is the one that so so people
you know again if the left uses that Roe
v Wade This percentage of America was
not for it but look what they did
there's a lot of different ways that
you're gonna have to uh um the political
strategists are going to be talking
about talk about this avoid talking this
that was was not a good timing that is
something we should avoid don't address
that there is no winning in that
argument we don't need to touch that
argument touch this argument push this
even harder that's what Trump did so
eloquently and abruptly in 2015 and 2016
that worked for him so it's going to be
a very unpredictable 15 16 17. well
that's the thing so Trump is slippery on
a lot of the really tough issues which
is a skill in a politician you know
DeSantis has the advantage or
disadvantage depending on the issue and
how you look at it of actually being in
Command right now down in Florida so you
know he just signed off on that bill
that moved the abortion limit back to
six weeks that's going to be
controversial in the general election
this has been a very animating issue for
the left for women who are in the center
even some you know center-right women
who are pro-choice for whom this is an
important issue might hold that against
him Trump is yes he gave us the three
Supreme Court Justices who overturned
jobs but he's slippery on this stuff and
can't necessarily be pinned down as well
as you would like him to I can speak to
that firsthand
[Music]